I just asked about the exact same
question but I'm curious for you do you
view this season as a failure
oh my God uh
okay because I'm not that up
we you asked me the same question last
year Eric okay uh do you get do you get
the promotion every year
on your job no right so every year you
work is a failure yes or no no every
every year you work you work towards
something two years ago right which is
to get a promotion to be able to uh take
care of your family to be able I don't
know
um provide the house for them or take
care of your parents you work towards
ago it's not a failure it's steps to
success you know and if you've never I
don't know I don't want to I don't want
to make it personal so there's always
steps to it you know
um Michael Jordan played 15 years won
six Championship the other nine years
was a failure
that's what you're telling me
no I'm actually a question yes or no
okay exactly so why are you asking that
question
it's a wrong question there's no failure
in sports
you know there's good days bad days some
days some days you are able to uh be
successful so that you're not some days
it's your turn so this is not your turn
and that's what sport is about you don't
always win some other other people's
gonna win and this year somebody else is
going to win similar that we're going to
come back next year try to be better try
to build good habits try to uh play
better not have a 10-day stretch with uh
playing bad basketball you know and
hopefully we can win the championship so
50 years from 1971 to 2021 that we
didn't win the championship it was 50
years of failures
no it was not
he was steps to it you know and we were
able to win one hopefully we're giving
another one
you know I'd show you that I didn't want
to make it personal because she asked me
the same question last year and last
year
I was in the in the uh right
um mind space to answer the question
back